bonjour et bienvenue dans le studio
diagonale tv spéciale championnat de
france à juin 2016 mais je suis avec
rien moins que le champion en titre
christian bauer bonjour question salue
enfin alors un début de tournoi un peu
difficile au depor
et puis finalement ça y était quasiment
en tête ce soir
oui mais tout dépend de la partie de
jean françois joly qui vraiment
surprenant dont je savais qu'il fallait
se méfier de lui d'ailleurs j'ai perdu
mon parti mais je m'attendais pas à ce
qui ce qui est des buts aussi bien ouais
donc oui mais c'est vrai qu'il a fait il
a été assez étonnant jusqu'à présent
mais bon surtout voilà tu nous as fait
tu nous as fait quand même de belles
parties après voilà des débuts un peu
difficiles et puis voilà que tu es
toujours là et aujourd'hui une victoire
hyper importante je dirais en termes
techniques m'ont d'abord parce qu'elle
est belle mais en terme sportif c'est
l'ami tournoi et te revoilà en tête
donc cela disons que j'étais voyage
était un peu déçu de ne pas avoir gagné
hier mais appartement où j'ai été mieux
dans la finale hier c'était je n'ai plus
beaucoup de temps c'était compliqué oui
parce que tu joues gozzoli qui était qui
fait aussi un super tournoi cette année
là il est chaud et tu as tu été à deux
doigts de le renverser un oui il a mal
évalué la position qu'on a vu après le
sens accru son sacrifice de qualité mois
il s'est trompé
parce que bon optiquement il allait il à
la paire de fou il a un voire deux pions
dès qu'ils ont passés sur les droits
mais ses pions passion sont beaucoup
plus lents que que ce que je peux faire
moi sur les dames en prenant b3 maison
donc monter tous m'ont finalement cet
amoureux du tap savait et noir quand
même mais bon tu aurais pu serrer
l'emporter
on peut comprendre que oui toi tu es
mené le chercher la victoire alors
aujourd'hui tu joues et sébastien masi
qui est quand même un client
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france
d'ailleurs sélectionné en équipe de
france alors pas par lui on nous
expliquait qu' il ya eu un comité qui
qui a décidé de le déguster comme power
point et fonctionnement sélectionné
voilà d'accord et donc c'est un super
joueur aussi tu comment tu abordé match
contre sébastien m'a dit bon on se
connaît depuis depuis longtemps déjà
joué un paquet de partie en tout cas
danse confondues est bon il a il a fait
des progrès récemment là
je suis d'accord avec lui que c'était sa
plume ce parti depuis très longtemps
ouais et mais il a battu plusieurs
joueurs à 2700 depuis un an et demi que
bon ben voila je savais que ça devait
pas être facile finalement quelque part
ça l'a été parce qu'il a vraiment mal
joué mais ils assez mal oui symbole qui
depuis quelques jours il a l'air de
jouer des parties et le problème
d'ordinateur
ah bon ainsi ça aurait des problèmes de
préparation dans le moteur a craché donc
il a dû en acheter un autre avis ça
complique d'accord ça l'a perturbé
peut-être effectivement dans sa
préparation
alors on va regarder cette partie roman
va parents n'hésitent tous les coups
parce qu'elle est un peu long et peu
technique on va donner une grande idée
peut-être regarder un peu la fin ou la
combinaison finale a lieu
oui oui combinaison en fait c'était
c'est un bien grand mot en ce qu'il m'a
donné une pièce mais de la position
était alors on va regarder ça en
essayant de ne pas être trop long parce
que la finance une partie de tendue
quand même on va voir donc tu alors tu
démarres tuer les blancs moi je jouais
des catalogues la rampe un larron 3
j'avais joué que quatre premiers
courriers pour tenter de surprendre
l'instant voilà et et je pensais qu'ils
allaient qu'il ait changé aussi donc
revenir par plutôt revenir l'élite
indienne que jouer qui a mis m6 et le
sis au besoin d'accord tu avait anticipé
ça oui bah il faut il bouge normal un
bon d'accord donc on y va donc donc tu
t'es pas trompé alors hein c'est ça tac
g6 tu te dis je c'est bon voilà il est
rentré dans ce que
ce que j'attendais et tu te sens tu est
du coup assez confiance quand on a gagné
un peu le l'anticipation au début c'est
déjà bien oui mais après forcément aussi
quand je joue quelque chose que lui ne
peut préparer il va prendre part répété
dont les quelques parties qu'il a dans
la base sur la variante et en
l'occurrence c'est quand il a joué ses 5
d'accord c'était plus que j'avais
regardé quoi donc on regarde on y va tac
tout cela ça va je crois il assez simple
c'est la c5 voilà donc oui parce que ce
qu'on se disait dans le direct
d'ailleurs souvent les 7 années de ses
parts ou cinq concours oui et donc là
c'est autre chose parce que ça peut
transposer des fois dans un combi banco
ou dans des bananiers dans des benoni
dans des trucs
voilà donc un bon dessin là par exemple
qui peut jouer p5 et on est dans un
grand bingo parce que peuvent apprendre
du cavalier elle qui encadrent obligé de
prendre confiance et qui a si ses trios
nier quoi donc on y va e.cisse donc là
il choisit sa plus tôt donc ça cib inoni
alors après s'il veut jouer comme dans
la partie il a peut-être plutôt intérêt
à jouer cinq ans d'un coup à ce moment
là je vais peut-être jouer différemment
et oui là il peut pas jouer c'est
maintenant non mais plutôt la règle 6
puis aux cinq as oui oui oui bah oui
parce qu'il a joué au 6 + 1 qu'il aurait
pu tenter eux cinq tout de suite oui en
essayant de faire quoi cavaliers 8 900
ses seins déjà pas perdre le tempo qu'il
accorde déjà tout simplement mai
par contre ils jouent aux cinq super
obligé de jouer fou détroit et attirante
que je voulais exigé quatre peut-être
que l'opposition fermait et oui et oui
parce que pomme oui parce que 2,5 qui
veut aller vite pour jouer cinq lequel
youtube scène et en jouant g4 déjà tu
anticipes toute poussée f5 et du
contrôle a tué archi contrôlée sein
d'accor bon c'est parce qu'il a fait de
toute façon donc on y va tous des trois
tranquille ça c'est normal à 6 donc
c'est déjà un peu suspect le principal
c'est puis on prend des cinq way et à ce
moment là bas j'ai pu entreprendre de
pions et du plan c bon ceci dit salaire
de tonte normale parce qu'ils essaient
de oui mais alors là si je pèse 5 tu
seras pas que j'aie de prendre non plus
un mais cinq ouais je pense que j'ai pas
joué à 4 gilles petit rock d'accord donc
voyez pas inquiet sur bessin qui te dit
je prends pas éventuellement même jeu
que je vois quatre plus tard c'est ça
éventuellement ouais ouais d'accord
est-ce que tu le laisses pas dans ces
quatre est oui a pas de risque tu te
tiennent bien le centre on n'y a pas de
problème d'accord ça s'appesantir trop
sur ce début ou 5 effectivement ils
perdent tempo le voit ici parce qu'ils
nous vendent deux fois mais là j'ai
donné l'adresse comment donc
ici tourner un bon là ya plein de
possibilités je peux je fous g5 aussi
pour ces trois caches cissé après six
fois le 3 donc on met un jour ou l'autre
je jouais b4 donc très bien c'est utile
pour b est donc toujours battre à l'aide
d'armes tu vas 300 tu vas y si tu vas
attendre c'est à lui plutôt de percer
pour exploiter la main mais c'est pas si
simple
c'est pas si simple ouais d'accord donc
habillage c'est normal
l'europe lui fait recaler 8 peut être
aussi oui donc la communion malgré un
jeu simple c'est que pretoria
s'ils jouent f5 et que je prends il peut
pas prendre du plomb oreille alors tu as
fait tourner donc là ici et alors le
problème de 15,5 effectivement c'est que
la dame le tapin c'est toujours un souci
ça parce que on se dira je sais que
c'est pas mal parce qu'on vise sf4 mai
mais en cas d'échec rapide mais on a un
problème après prise du pied emprise du
pur lecavalier dans l'air qui a géré
prend 1,5 à lesperon 5les fois qu'avec
des gestes simples au sein là c'est un
problème des joueurs de standing ça on
hésite toujours a ajouté régis schultz a
un petit peu akaïev 4 du coup ça enlève
le problème est
mais ce cavalier alors tu as oui tu es
revenu en f1
et là tu tiennes tout tu domines ce
cavalier finalement en quelque sorte oui
bon cavalier tout seul peut pas faire
grand chose peut pas faire tout chose
bon je pouvais aussi prendre je vous le
thème des deux puits auca tout 5
voilà ça lui donne est peut-être plus
que de jeu que dans la partie
voilà tu le dis oh et puis tu peux
toujours plus tard le faire exactement
tu prends ici puis on prend ça on
l'avait vu aussi des possibilités bon ça
reste technique donc qui choisit h6 noël
c'est bien secouer un jeu parce que
c'était un jour sans
oui c'est parce que le 6 il veut quoi
faire ici fait j'essaye le problème
c'est qu'ils vont avoir énormément de
mal après l'affairé faisait donc
finalement il ce qui coince ça sa propre
contre attaque
presque oui on a l'impression qu'il
voulait attendre de voir ce que j'allais
fermer mais tu vas le faire
c'est l'impression que ce coût est un
petit peu en dessous quoi il aurait
fallu tenter peut-être f5 ou ce genre de
choses c'est que là on se demande à quoi
ça rime parce qu'après à trois qui
prépare tu vas tu prépares b4 tu vas
avoir le jeu classique des blancs
allèles dames avec l'ouverture quand tu
veux de la poule b et lui normalement il
faut qu'il fasse quelque chose ici pour
pour contrer parce que sinon il va faire
qu être que passifs mais c'est ce qui va
se passer
bon il a fait g5 mais ça fait plus de
mal contre le voilà j'ai cinq meilleurs
j'essaie voilà il c'est fini pour être
simple à sa mort mais puisque je veux
simplement je prendrai la case au delà
prochain voilà quelle est la reprise de
cavaliers h deux jours plusieurs pick up
tout de suite si oui alors tu laisses
faire j'ai quatre c'est ça alors moitié
parce que ben et coach et 4 points
chacun admettons b4g 4 donc tu prends
mais sur une perte de temps elle prime
sexy prendre du fou maintenant je peux
le prendre c'est sain qu'il y avait sept
qui traîne ses 5 puis on prend et
bessette et emprise alors évidemment il
ya un pion passé parfois c'est pas grave
parce que les noirs arrivée m en
cavalier ici mais en plus cela en plus
il ne vaut pas comment le cas il
pourrait venir d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs ici peut-être aussi
il y avait faute contre 4 en plus 6 605
et leur écrasement centrale oui ça leur
donne pas l'air d'être bon donc là du
coup c'est assez linéaire après calais
h2 en plus tu toute possibilité il peut
même pas jouer quatre essais on se dit
là il va faire que subir la partie en
fait c'est ce qui s'est passé à cinq
quand même bon lycée de au moins se dit
en cas d'ouverture bo - il va ouvrir un
peu sa colonne à s'asseoir au moins ça
de pris et la gt3 le g3 tiens puisque
s'il prend h 30
mais je vais j'ai quatre ans ferme et le
fou à voilà donc quand on regarde ça
rapidement en cas de cavaliers prend h
trois échecs on prend fou prend h3 et
maintenant g4 et le foot enfermé voilà
donc 5 way h5 et la détresse trois
employés toute l'herbe on prend les
trois problèmes en f3 et se fout et
alerte définitivement fermé peut-être on
peut alors qu'entre les f2 à la
formation cavaillé ici donc faut jouer
la dame et cavaliers des incas les deux
bouffons tranquille c'est tranquille il
ya quelques coups à jouer mais il a des
gros soucis corps est d'accord donc ici
j'ai trois donc il ne prend pas il
focalise ici et là tu te dis pourrait
passer à la casserole c'est la cata
positionnement
des faiblesses de partout il puis évoque
un conte région cavaliers g4 tranquille
maintenant c'est toi qui prends plus de
l'air à la loi donc tu tiens les deux
ailes ici tu casses quand tu veux tu te
presque pas si le fait au bon moment et
là tu entraînes parce que là tu veux
devenir en bo3 et tu verrouille
complètement la case f5 défini il est
fils et après je pourrai le faire
c'était assez triste qu'elle ait des
sept recalés aux 3 c'est fini donc la
les noirs n'ont plus de jeu plus
possibilité jamais de jouer cent
c'est ça donnerait tout leur ai donné le
four bon bref se saouler après 2 mai
monstrueux et il existe ici jouer c'est
ainsi la page d'accueil les pcistes sûr
que jouer le faux de fougères fou de
foot et 4 essayer de les changer en plus
de rajouter de la pression sur 5,8 même
tout simplement et de bloquer
complètement en tout cas les noirs
allaient le droit sont bloqués voilà du
fait qu'on tient cette case qui me casse
clé dans les structures estonienne il
faut pouvoir attaquer sur ims health a
fait pression sur qu'axa savent où est
la dernière donc ils vont subir mais
parfois en subissant on arrive à tenir
lors l'occurrence on va voir que nos
qualifs 6 ils ont triste les cavaliers
aux siens parce qu'ils sont rares il
arrivait au maximum pas vraiment de ce
qui pouvait faire c'est à dire qu'il est
que dans son camp il ne peut pas faire
un peu rêver
et puis ils vont s'ils essaient de jouer
avec h5 à ce moment là géré avec 5 puis
le pion j'ai cinq heures et le pion g5
qui est attaqué par le problème
c'est que je bouge et deux rouges et
deux l'idée c'est que sur age 5 900
qu'il a pas de l'astuce avec cavaliers
prend 1,4 sur h5 on joue kf5 parce que
le fou attaque g5 et ya même pas de
cavaillé prend le cas puisque on reprend
du fou et lecavalier n'est protégé voilà
ce que sinon il ya des petites astuces
un accord donc ici tour et huit bombes
et il fait ce qu'il dit et lison ici
stratégiquement s'était déjà cédé jared
il fait ça pour essayer de vous offrir
des six parce que tu es en plus et à la
casse bessèges
tu vas pouvoir mettre un cavalier kathak
des six donc il y va il garder une case
pour le fou sans doute donc on y va
souder 2 en tranquille quand tu fais tu
termines en développement tu te prépares
pour jouer b4 un fou 17 et maintenance à
laisser leurs attaques alors prise
prises et b6 alors classique il essaie
de tenir maintenant quatre prix sans
doute eu rope rendu qu'une baie et tu
alors tu vas attendre de quoi tu vas
essayer de doubler sur la colombe et
avant de pouvoir pénétrer blessés ou
alors on reprend la main ouvre
grandement la partie bien sûr prendra
colonel ils comptent contester cette
colonne
alors que les blancs peuvent la prendre
par les noirs les noirs sont resserrés
c'est à dire qu'ils ont que trois halles
trois lignes alors que les noms et blanc
on en 4 et donc qui forcément c'est
qu'il ya plus en plus d'air voilà et
l'accueil des simples on s'y fait fou
prend j'aurai quelques instants plus
tard et puisque tu peux aussi me lancer
car je peux aussi mais on sait qu'à
qu'on va se passer pas mal parce que
après la prise ici après
c'est triste position et triste info et
suit donc la passivement et avait froid
et oui là j'attends des tours à deux
puis faire tu auras 2 c'est parce qu'il
a fait un nom lors ya peut-être une
autre aux idées de contrôle où s'est
jouée la bdf 4 un moment j'apprends
pranger prend un frein à tête le
cavalier voilà ce qu'elle voulait bout
je prendre en 4 voire deux pions et
ils ont que ça gigote est un petit peu
par rapport à la partie ouvrait d'accord
donc là je pensais faire tour d un tout
simplement tour ici protège le fou voilà
avec l'idée de jouer maintenant au tour
t'auras de contester la colonne revenir
ici il peut pas doubler et maintenant il
peut jamais penser qu'à laisser cette
voie la façon qu'ils protègent d'abord
l'équipe de m6 est donc bon bah oui oui
en plus
ah oui le calice et bien sûr la dent
bref trois blocs la dame en débit donc
du coup il la colonne arrête à toi en
fait oui c'est moi du coup la cavalière
4 et j'imagine que ça suffit comme donc
les flatte tu prends oui ah oui alors
gala tour et le cavalier témoin hier
donc le prendre je prends tour
maintenant et cavaliers attaque 4 mais
tu jouerais cavalier est simple quand
même atteint 11,4 je sais pas où je
théâtre bon d'accord et j'ai quatre
pussy mais qu'avait l'épreuve 4 branle
et maintenant sans doute tout simplement
parfois un tabac une pièce un toit
ouais ouais bon faut un examen qui est
bien il ya un peu de ça ne bouge pas
beaucoup plus que dans la partie
ouais c'est vrai lieu réputé selon toi
t'aurais joue s'est débarrassé de suite
là je pense ouais ouais alors bon je
réfléchisse si j'avais mieux que mieux
tabler j4 ouais j'ai vu qu'il avait
avalé ces trois qui existait il semble
ici cavaliers c3 c3 à l'autre cavalli
qui attaquent la tour voilà parce que
bon temps pour manger de plus donc s'y
prend le 3 je prends la torah 2.3 tu
prends la tour à deux têtes à la qualité
en la qualité du ghana qualité donc
j'allais enfin à huy et l'intérêt de
qualité trop intermedia c'est que bien
sûr tout contrôle canola et oui d'accord
donc c'est sans doute plus fort c'est un
choix entre les pièces pour le pion la
qualité ça a l'air mieux j'ai imaginé
que je leur dit de suite et était bien
salaires plus solide donc ici il fait
roger 7 alors ils contrôlent le
qu'alexis puisqu'on a vu dans les
différentes variantes il a besoin de
pouvoir bouger la dame donc ça permet
elle mais il peut pas vraiment en plus
parce qu'il y avait toujours calé c'est
cet ampli donc la tour 1 normal tu
prends la colonne tour prend tout
reprend donc la tête ou pas colonnes la
dénomination al-dam le pauvre sébastien
durand donc là tu es confiant quand même
du oui voila j'ai le jeu c'est que la
position et les infusions est excellente
la ducale ici je fus commis hier et que
je gagne ou pas je rentre à la maison
mais c'est pas pareil herlies si
l'avantagé stable et puis
ouais parce qu'il ya le problème de la
finale c'était qu'elle était
déséquilibrée et puis j'avais beaucoup
moins de temps aussi et ça aurait pu mal
tourner d'accord donc on poursuit dans
bay 8 donc la wii peut pas aller
ailleurs un de toute façon donc là ils
essaient de se donner un peu d'air et la
torah si ce support totalement sur 3,6
pour en fait je préfère vous étreint je
voulais pas de jouer trop tôt pour viser
pour mettre le roi sur la sur la
diagonale du roi sur le fond sur la
diagonale du roi et une autre idée c'est
que quand je fais cavaliers f5 échelle
on s'en fout plein j en prends le talent
est de bouger
oui ils savaient plus compliqué pour lui
de jouer 4 et oui les cavaliers ça il
peut pas mais il peut pas c'est pas 2
c'est compliqué c'est qu'il peut pas si
peu quand même
il peut quand même essayer ouais mais il
sera cloué pendant les soit loué ça va
c'est plus dur pas d'accord il peut
quand même mais c'est plus dur tour à 6
mais non là j'ai eu un petit doute si je
jouais comme b737 d'un v8 dan 17 ou à
vie parce que ils menacent plus grands
cavaliers donc c'est pas stable ah oui
donc à ce moment-là un plomb je décide
si je vous qui avez dit avec cinq échecs
à quelqu'un il va faire il faut prend
effectivement si on pense qu'il peut
couvrir un peu le jeu avec eux quatre
ouais d'accord ou alors il y avait une
combinaison oui alors admettons les
coups à jouer tout à fait
donc tu me dis tu me lis tu joues les
coûts occasionnés fait ouais hein baissé
de la torah scène pour pas perdre de
temps d'un v8 est là maintenant cavalier
singles idée de quatrième scène c'est
que vous aussi le roi s'en va le
cavalier là il est en prise et l'idée
c'est que on veut que ce fou s'échangent
de manières que ce que la menace francs
cavaliers n'existe plus voilà donc ça
c'est la suite positionnelle donc là il
prend du fou tu prend du plomb tu
pourrais prendre aussi prendre la dame
est donc je vais je vais y réfléchir
entre les deux vraies mais voilà le
problème c'est qu'il a eu quatre
nouveau i du code quartier gigote un peu
parce qu'effectivement il donne un peu
d'air notamment la dame de bouger et de
cavaliers là il va aller en cinq sans
doute oui ça donc ils attaquent c4 et
gesticulant existe recule un peu même si
la torah 7 est monstrueuse lecavalier b5
et toulon pénible et que bombay oui et
le fou là il va quand même avant une
diagonale magnifique et donc la
combinaison dont je peux ramener c'était
lieu de faire cavalier f5 c'était lui
reprend 17
alors au lieu de faire as-tu voulait
prendre prendre la qualité donné la
qualité d'accord en cavale et veyran
khalef 5 est maintenant khalip cinq
échecs roy en a je suis probablement
alors
oui cela que c'est pas si claire was set
et gratuitement les décès qui avait fait
flamber 6
et oui un état d'âme province est alors
qu'il faut pour un oui c'est très
compliqué mais ça a l'air bon parce que
la machine pour en moins pour deux pions
et je sus des 6 et 17 et qu'il pourrait
faire la passe que tu vas prendre des
6es la tour est en prison oui donc ça a
l'air bon un calcul et met d'accord donc
les dons et avait tout vu donc il n'a
pas fait ça il a fait tout s'est vite
mais c'est un peu triste
ces passifs quoi parce que là tu vas
jouer à tuer toi d'où tu fais pas ton à
cette mélangeront tour à sept tours 7
non sans doute il joue tours 7 mais
sinon il y avait aussi ce fou de cette
queue en fait je il reviendra 17 verset
pas question à ce que la maison marche
ou pas c'est la même date mais
maintenant je préfère améliorer
tranquillement d'accord donc la foux
ossète
ils essaient de repositionner ses pièces
autant qu'il peut c'est vrai que ce
fouillis triste aussi parce qu'il est
derrière ses poulains donc je pensais
plutôt il veut faire quoi tu aurais
suite là est enclin à f/5 que plus tard
quand même je vous des coûts quoi donc
cavalia 7
on approche de la fin je veux prendre le
fou donc si tu veux prendre ce fou parce
que vilain c'est le sait la seule pièce
bonne parce que les pions sur noir
évidemment un contrôle et cazaux poser
est alors un peu plus tard à casser si
cela donc bon je vais fallait vérifier
un tout petit peu d'âme à 8 mai
à 8h damas huit puisque le cavaly serait
cloué sur la tour voilà mais toujours et
quads à me2 peut-être dans le juste
jouer dam des aides à madame 1 pourrait
sinon et à quel point ce but qui est
intéressant à quand même lui qui avait
été construite à me prend 1,2 alors il y
avait ce cavalier français 8 on peut
regarder dans ce cas là on donne
effectivement la tour fin contrefout pas
tout à fait donner la cavalier f5 celui
là un f5 et il ya cette médiation lieu
le fou si on va donc là il va ensuite
pour le mans ouais il va lier
un des deux prend mettons cavaliers f
prends ça tu sud a oui parce qu'elle est
le cas et si ce qui est toujours en
crise car les mains de l'éperon
cavaliers il reprendrait du cavalier
l'enclavé l'épreuve des 6 1
c'est compliqué hein oui c'est ok oui et
là donc ils prendraient le footsie prend
le foot proxy ces jouets mattel est
alors dans ce cas là tu prends un f6 tu
menaces maths et tout en ayant la tour
entreprises donc tu récupères au moins
tout avec une position bien foutu parce
que des 6 et sauter dans tous les pions
sauter quui ouais d'accord est bon c'est
pas mal donc ça devrait
ça devrait suffire ça devrait être pas
mal oui donc c'est donc tellement huit
taureaux et même dû sacrifier
oui mais donc sinon d'âme des uns est
tranquille quoi donc dans les deux cas
exclu toute façon il est trop lent pour
profiter du temps qu'il fait ou 17
bon donc il continua gesticule un peu là
tu as le choix et bitume a cassé six
mois tranquille donc la télé oui parce
que tu veux éliminer se fout en fait il
était tendu parce que le cabinet tient
monsieur devient monstrueux si la
sellette
on y voit assez clair dame s'est vite
hélas tout simplement 3 703 7 alors quoi
l'idée tu veut sacrifier encore sur des
syndromes active goethe à petit la
pression
éventuellement je sacrifie en 17 6
si ça gagne ainsi sa mère évidemment on
est soudé 8
il ya encore quelques coups quand même
oui il ya encore quelques coups mais
cinq baies 5
as-tu verrouille complet en plus
maintenant ce cavalier devient un brin
lassé ses souffrances 1 pour le noir
comme un musicien cavaliers au 7 avril
au mépris h3
la fin je pense que oui parce qu'ici il
peut avec dame ici il peut attaquer h3
alors au lieu de jouer cavalier seul qui
préférait hanche il vous prend h3 c'est
vrai que c'est encore une petite menace
il faut faire gaffe quand même donc la
torre fait quoi ici donc si je dois voir
fou prend vous prend comme prendre la
dame prend et 4,5
voilà le fameux le roi va en page 7 non
même joie et bouger en huit saisons g8
admettons d'accord qu'elle prendrait six
on prend des six plateaux est attaquée
mais de jeu kevin asch qui a pris sur
attention ici ah oui donc c'est
dangereux ça mais c'est parce que en
fait parce qu'ils attaquent la date tu
vas dans ma chair un seul coup oui on
est d'accord
la dame est attaqué on peut pas prendre
ce qu'il ya dedans pendant machin
d'alger car évidemment gilles platret
meiway peut-être c'est dangereux c'est
dangereux parce qu'il ya dans madame d1
derrière il ya peut-être des trucs comme
n'est peut-être qu'un cavalier qui vient
en échec si pendu oui donc ça ce ne
devait pas fait ce n'était pas le mieux
donc sur fourrages trois fous princes 3
c'est pas sûr qu'il faille prendre tout
simplement en s'offrant h3 peut-être
tout ce que tu fais rien ou tu fais là
il n'y a peut-être pas y est pas une
menace c'est ici sur 27 sont en train de
voir non pas de menaces directes où j'ai
mangé 4 marche pas non plus ainsi
peut-être non non pas g4 tendu comme un
as mais c'est pas si simple donc
il aurait pu tenter sa roue alors sur
faut prendre soin d'un proche trois
dames f5
oui mais si je voulais 4 il aura plus de
100 attaques
j'ai vu qu'il y avait aussi le 25 mai
votre méthode fou prend d'en prendre dès
maintenant des médecins qu'ils avaient
l'idée est bien sûr si dans prendra mais
on prend avec de la vanille et puis ça y
est on a placé notre cavalier je le
comprend des cisailles et agressif qui
tourne
il faut qu'il faisait cap pour tenter
quelque chose et là mais maintenant il
ya plus de pénalités plus d'idées alors
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire comme il faut
quand même joli coup mari si cette dame
est ce qu'on peut pas les prendre
peut-être y mais moi non je pas sur les
milliers de fous d'être sacrément tour à
tour à 8 ha oui tour à 8-8 attaque le
fou ou valfond obligé de jouer fossé ce
cavalier à wicca tacle daoui stand où on
peut prendre le cavalier sectionnelles
aussi mais je sais pas si ça sert à
quelque chose
enfin si c'est priest est vite prise f5
prise f5
ah oui on pourrait encore du jus et oui
dans le ciel devient compliqué mais ça
devient compliqué mais ça t'aurait plus
ça de jouer ça on va pas regarder tous
les coups mais je peux mais il va se
prendre c'est plus simple prise au cette
vision prendre un set foot reprend je
prends 8h quand jacques à toi qu'on
prend 1,8
voilà le câble libres 1 et à la fin j'ai
quatre tombes oui c'est le mieux ou
peut-être même dans la meute et 7 ou
peut-être même dans 17 gagne tout de
suite
effectivement sur le fou sur le canon
est encore la camdiac saint louis
c'est là ça y est sont ils plus septième
plus parce qu'il ya aussi folle si ce
fou quand même belle combine ouais
d'accord donc cavalier le set
elle n'était pas si simple il aurait pu
prendre trois c'était quand même à
partir de là il n'a jamais essayé
ouais toutes les combines il vise à les
haïr et aiguilles c'est bizarre ouache 2
bon maintenant il y avoir maintenant il
n'y a plus rien donc issifou c7 est
maintenant donc là j'hésite entre terme
d'un fossé pousser encore en a c'est
vrai que mine de rien est encore hyper
complexe parce qu'il ya tous les pions
sauf sauf les pions à
complexe lui et non parce qu'il a
vraiment 15e match contre jeunes et on
voit que quand même on voit bien que dès
que dès que ça s'anime un peu ça devient
calculatoire avec des sacrifices
possibles des contre attaques sur leroy
c est non il ya des coups il faut quand
même avoir le coeur à approcher parce
qu'il est compliqué aussi c'est avec la
chaleur etc
au bout d'un moment on peut faire pas
mal de gayant quoi faire des mais la
preuve on a bien eu dans le féminin on a
eu un tour siarrouy la part avec al ahli
bank - ou que ça peut arriver donc
demandé un bien tu vas tout tu vas aller
sur la colonne ah oui donc la justice si
je peux jouer le coup c'est demain
demain des macaques à 6,6 à mach 4 à 6
on élimine donc là de nouveau il devait
essayer de faire quelque chose peut-être
tâche 5 un moment même si j'ai 5 et les
faibles oui ça affaiblit gsm à 10h tu
sais pas si clair non plus où il va
après parce que s'ils s'y fait hk tu
peux éventuellement faire j'ai quatre il
fait j'ai que tu peux faire h4 et tu es
toujours beaucoup mieux il n'a pas de
jeu et c'est bien le problème c'est
qu'il n'a pas réussi à s'activer
il aurait fallu qu'ils tentent les
choses un peu limite donc ici cavaliers
fg huit bombes et c'est un coup
d'attendre sa base et son confrère il
défend qui abolit au 7 mai toutes ces
pièces sont sur deux rangées là oui bah
oui il est quand même
bien ficelé c to c 3 donc ça ça fait
plaisir parce qu'on se dit à tout moment
peut-être même ans je peux envisager de
jouer f4 maintenant et f4 parce que ça
ouvrait complètement la position d'une
là évidemment j'ai des choses comme
prise en hausse inquiète des six qui
primerait sur des sacrifices aussi
possible de lui parce qu'en plus tu as
des six derrière cavaler prendre
comprend des six la dame étant là ça
fait une fourchette
c'est possible faut calculer un parce
que la teneur mobilise de s'attaquer etc
bref non c'est le truc qui traînent food
et vite
et la belle a simplement qu'elle allait
prendre les 8es s'il reprend tout
reprendre 17
et là c'est moi et après la tour puis
ressortir à prendre le cavalier crise de
temps ce moment là pour lui non ils
devaient 20 minutes met dans la position
était trop épuisée quoi ces curieuses
effectivement là cette partie ce qu'on
peut retenir c'est qu'il n'ait pas pris
sa chance dans les moments un peu tendue
de seuil et de compliquer si je pense
que si j'avais eu moins de temps la
pendule du nord il aurait peut-être
essayé mais là ça fait confiance dans le
calcul peut être non mais disons que oui
quand j'ai encore un quart d'heure après
at il espéré que j'avais
tellement mal de temps et puis avant sa
chance plus tard quand d'accord quand
j'ai eu vraiment le temps de calculer
tout mais alors comment tu vas j'irai
maintenant la flamme torres 4 - bell
internet s'est de nouveau en tête donc
l'hôte est bien placé pour regarder ton
titre ça serait pas mal baisse alors
qu'on a on en a parlé lors du direct
il ya que deux joueurs qui ont gardé
leur titre c'est jane pour moment ces
quinze dernières années il ya etienne
est l'outil est aussi lautier dans les
années 2000 bacon à l'arrêt tiéné 5 fois
de suite oui bien donc ça a aidé la
garder pour le revers des siens mais
sinon à l'aller n'a pas beaucoup de
titres d'affilée c'est quoi c'est
possible en tout cas tu es bien placé il
te reste quoi comme match important la
fin tournoi évidente bon ce n'est pas
vraiment de partie vivante mais c'est
tigran laurent romain et mathieu allait
quand même du lourd
la nation ce national y a rien de facile
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup de
christian bauer champion de france pour
nous avons joué en studio diagonale tv
merci de nous avoir suivis et puis donne
donc rendez-vous à une prochaine fois au
revoir